Recently, China has combined two
practices to make significant political
and territorial gains in Asia without
crossing the threshold into open
conflict with the United States. First,
since the 1990s, China has focused on
low-cost ways to disrupt, disable, and
deny US' ability to operate in the region.
Instead of trying to compete directly
with US power projection capabilities,
China's ballistic and cruise missiles,
for example, hurt the US' ability to
come to the aid of Japan, Taiwan, or the
Philippines in the case of a conflict
with China. Second, since 2009, instead of
direct confrontation to push the United
States out of the Asia-Pacific, China has
engaged in activities below the
threshold of conflict. For example, China
has increased the risk to the United
States of operating in the South China
Sea by harassing US vessels and aircraft
with non-military platforms to maintain
a degree of deniability and discourage a
counter response. As a result, China has
gained more power and territorial
control in Asia without recourse.
Do you
think the United States should push back
more against China?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos and from AEI.